[Music]
hello good evening I am crew here - okay
we wanted to make a story about how to
maintain our self-esteem our dignity and
humanity during war times when I was in
survival it was a fantastic thing when I
met those women there who had beautiful
stories inspiring stories so I really
want to to dedicate this award to them
because I think they are true heroes I'm
very grateful to the Academy - to be
here and experience this whole week and
that they found our film word for this
amazing honor I would like to thank you
Sean Hector
Julia Devon and all you guys who made
this week possible and to meet all those
young devoted and talented directors who
will make fantastic things in the future
I'm sure about that
also I'm very proud to represent hungry
and hungry and filmmaking here tonight
so I want to turn to the Hungarian
National Film Fund to support us and
also the University of Theatre and film
arts and all the teachers there my lead
teachers ildikó anody nurse and Attila
Janish also my cast also outside school
teachers or mentors issuance of and
Alexander managed my cast million a Long
Beach ready to pitch then a pitch in a
row Jory Laszlo cassock and of course
weather on abortion which without her
talent this film would be wouldn't be
the same I would like to thank to my
fantastic crew my producers domicile
Tasha GABA Rocha
Monika Mitch Norah awfully my line
producer Patricia didn t know my
screenwriter Gastonia Cameron my DOP
Davina Zoltan my later reduce capita
my son desire Gabbar balázs my
production designer last all right
costume designer you reaching courage in
the first ad assault on your way and
please allow me to thank to to my love
or she who is here tonight for
supporting me during the years of
filmmaking and also my mother who is
here tonight too
and I would like to thank her to taught
me how to fight for in life how to fight
for my dreams to become a filmmaker so I
think this is the ultimate proof for her
that it was good to not become a lawyer
and start to pursue my dreams so
academia thank you for that - thank you